I just always got all my skincare from
my like the females in my life I have a
great salt scrub for you check it over
here on this episode of spectrum we
wanted to explore the topic of
masculinity in the last couple of years
there's been intense scrutiny young
masculinity in America we traveled to
Chicago and partner with Gillette and
Walgreens to bring together a group of
men including NFL star first-round pick
and former Chicago Bears football player
Kyle long to demonstrate that men can
open up and tackle questions on topics
ranging from gender roles in society
showing emotion beauty and even skin
care our objective was to have an honest
conversation about what it means to be a
man today this is spectrum enjoy the
episode
well now I'm curious yeah I disagree
with the professional NFL players
because some of the most quote unquote
manly men in my life are musicians
actors people that I relied on as an
image of masculinity so to say that the
arts are less masculine than sports for
me doesn't make sense my mom's the
Chilean coach I think Chile is the sport
argue with her I'll never let her know I
think Shelly is this poor cuz I think
it's fun to argue with it like there's a
certain amount of masculinity like to do
all those alright to do the back flips
and like to push the girls up an air so
I feel like there is more masculinity
that's strive to just sports like then
there is two more of the are success
while somewhat agree if you put blood
sweat and tears into something that's
kind of what creates your character
losing getting knocked down getting back
up
I mean learning those kind of principles
at such a young age I think that's kind
of where helps create a sense of
strength that kind of helps carry you
into a certain sense of masculinity and
manhood as you get older so I'm an actor
one of my recent roles was donkey in
Shrek the musical
there was blood there was god-awful
sweat because a costume within the
crying yeah there was crying talking
about the physical aspect and I really
agree that there's physical on art and
in sports but then there's that mental
aspect you talked about like failure
getting back up like even before you got
that donkey oh how many people had to
get the audition for that role
definitely the arts can be right up with
their with sports sports R&R there you
go
one of the major things that has
impacted me would be my father and how
he viewed like film industry theatres
because it was something that was able
to connect to the human experience and
it was more personal and more emotional
locker room talk is part of being a man
3 2 1 go I'll start you know this phrase
locker room talk has taken on a life of
itself obviously in the past year it's
been a hot button issue and it has
changed since I was a six-year-old and I
said my first swear word and when mom
and dad said Kyle that's locker room
talk I also think about locker room talk
is like sexual in nature to someone is
gonna say it to you someone's gonna
initiate your locker room talk I mean I
think growing up playing sports and all
that I think it has found its own way
with this new locker room talk as of
2016 and I think that's kind of switched
to this weird sexual harassment I think
by the nature of the question though I'm
asking us this it is the people that are
crossing that line that we're talking
about is that part of it belittling
women not even if you're belittling
women but you're objectifying them
you're being cruel but you're like come
on I'm just joking around it's a locker
room
no man that's not what makes you a man
that's not something that should be part
of that I think men's main role in this
situation is stepping forward setting
boundaries and still having fun within
the framework of those bow
and respecting one another as a black
man I looked at it is like barbershop
talk yeah or so and I just feel like
it's just being a safe space for men to
be able to get those ideas out so like
if it's something that's like you find
extremely offensive and in the confines
of that safe space you I can say it you
could say hey this is why I think it's
offensive and I could say oh I never
thought about like that without having
to take that out into the world
realistically on the world I don't think
men have the you know opportunity to
express feelings and things like that
like they can in the locker room like
I'm sure you just locker rooms where
you've cried or you were able to have
other man's confront you say okay so
it's okay to cry in the same guys you
make funny or the same guys yes yeah I
notice that safe space there are a lot
of men out there that can operate
rationally not everything is like about
sex with us you know I'm saying so I'm a
Christian my father's a pastor to me
being a man is about you taking
responsibility you know
accountability my grandpa was a colonel
in the Vietnam War
fighting for the country of Laos and if
anyone needed a tank they would talk to
him anyone needed anything he was the
head Logistics commander and then my dad
he was like the head of a gang so he
kind of demanded respect and became the
head of everything and in turn both of
them were heads of our household I feel
like I have to be able to be the head of
the household and have people rely on me
when needed I just feel like when it
comes time for deference most of the
time women prefer to defer to men
leadership and my dad was a primary
breadwinner and then my dad got laid off
automatically my mom became the
breadwinner and they just switched those
roles but like when it came time for
decisions and stuff like that she still
deferred to him most of the time and
it's like we didn't miss a beat as a
family and I feel like that's what she
went out for like this with most men her
most women went from their men it's
better for the men to be in a position I
don't feel like a woman can't be in that
position
yeah I'm gonna build on what you're
talking about CJ because I feel like
each one of us has a unique set of
circumstances and in your case your dad
was really smart in terms of his you
know decision that's why your mom
probably relied on him for that stuff
and that's not to take anything away
from her but I'm over here on the
disagree
because the question was should a man be
the head of the household
verbatim correct yep now my response to
that is no there is no rules for who's
the head of the household what I make it
so I disagree with the comment I think
men can be but it's 20/20 and if I were
to tell you that I'm the head of my
household I'd be lying to you I think
there's a leader within each one of us I
don't think it has to do with whether
you're a man or a woman I know in my
household there are times that my wife
leads there's times I lead we talk about
leading up leading down we even let our
daughter lead sometimes my role is a man
and a father in my daughter's life is to
be the example and to be just supportive
and accepting and loving and I want her
to see by example that I'm always
striving to be the best human being I
can be that's really what my role is and
she's the greatest joy in my life I have
a salt scrub for you check it over here
oh I just always got all my skincare
opinion opinions from my like the
females in my life I don't know I just
didn't want to feel like I was letting
less than one man so I didn't want to
talk to other men as we all get older
our skin starts to look like that bag
that's been left aside too long and
that's why skincare recently has become
a thing for me I've talked about it a
bunch with with guys that's how I find
out about like beard oil mm-hmm wasn't
my wife that said you need it it was my
buddy with a beard that said hey beard
oils awesome I I can think of a couple
of friends did we talk about it pretty
regularly one of the guys was concerned
about skin cancer and if he wasn't
talking to the guys about it like hey
what do you do he might not have felt
comfortable talking to a woman about it
so we just cracked that open we just
talk about this stuff what did you talk
to the NFL player about you know just
the skincare I'll be the first to do
this I strongly agree I think it's
important to take pride in yourself and
have self-discipline I really I write it
all falls under discipline for me I'd
actually branch off that - because I
view it as
loving yourself it doesn't have to be
you take four hours to be able to make
yourself look good and presentable to be
able to walk out the door it'll provide
confidence for you to be able to do
whatever you want in the world I feel
like this is one of those conversations
that happens during locker room talk so
it may not be like I'm sure some of the
people are gonna be surprised like all
these guys talk about skincare but like
those are the conversations that you
have in those locker room talk
situations yeah I think it's important
you talk to you guys about skincare
maybe we live in Chicago I mean I'm a
serious white boy I think it's important
that when you're dealing with elements
it's cold it's frickin rough I mean
we're in construction it's a lot of a
lot of nasty stuff out there zone yeah
I'm fourth generation bricklayers now
that craft workers unions my dad my
grandpa my great-grandpa we're all union
representatives and it's everything my
family stands for believes in and
there's still fighting for I think for
me being a man you know standing up for
people standing up for what you believe
in
Sulc myself over here now guys never
made it this is a high bar
I am constantly still striving but my
father has different standards than me
and I'm proud of Who I am but there's a
small part of me that's just like I wish
I could hit that bar but it's also part
of me that's like there are some parts
of that bar that I'm not gonna touch
expectations as we all know within the
family can be very tough and I know
you've alluded to this a few times today
and I feel for you I really do like in
my heart I just want to give you a huge
hug because I have a dad who has honor
it whether he knows he's putting them on
me or not
there's unrealistic expectations the
name on the back of my Jersey we share
the number I chose to wear was the same
that he wore profession the same I will
never be my dad because he was a world
beater in his field but I also in the
journey striving for his acceptance I
found myself proud of Who I am
and that is being a man yeah and being
your own man and like I really I really
hope we can find you if we have this
conversation again I really hope that we
can have you at least on the somewhat
because I struggle with that too and
it's a real thing I can't think of any
time in my life when my dad has ever
said he's been disappointed in me it's
been nothing but encouragement he always
he asked for my help on things now it's
like he's always telling other people
how his problem he's like yeah I read to
your dad he was telling me everything
about you so and I know I guess like a
lot of people like don't even have their
fathers in their life so like I
appreciate it that much more I love that
you guys all have that talking about
what negative consequences we have as
men for holding it in and for not being
able to voice our emotions I think that
I faith my dad passed away because he
took his own life because he didn't he
didn't express emotion it wasn't in his
definition of being a man and so because
of that he bottled everything up to the
point where I didn't know what was going
on and I was the closest individual to
him and at that point is just mentally
and physically mentally emotionally not
stable and it destroys
person no matter how manly of men
destroy you from the inside one of the
few things I remember before he passed
he said to me I can't believe I'm such a
tiger and I have a son and turns out to
be kitten and they're just demoralizing
words MIT by dad would say and those
things just stick with me so I would
never put myself across that line but I
always work to get to someone to
disagree so that uh I can feel that I
got to as close as I can to his bar
that's a shame man because you're
standing here and you're saying your
words and you're standing up to it
you're a man doorman you should be over
here yeah man I see it was yeah yeah
don't know what that you could use my
dad if you want I am the son of the
oldest child and the only son of the
oldest child so that kind of just makes
a lineage that I had to follow and that
person disappearing drops weight on my
shoulders all eyes are on me now I take
the center stage and that made me feel
like I have to be a man I never really
had the chance to be vocal about my dad
I felt safe enough to talk about it and
it was one of the first times that all
these emotions that I've bottled up have
finally come to light
[Music]
let's go come again I will challenge
accepted
I'm proud to be a man because of who we
are right now evolving our thinking of
becoming more sensitive to others my
experience today was one in which I
gained a lot of understanding and
respect for specifically the men that
were in here we talked about tough
topics we were honest we weren't afraid
to call each other out and I think
respect was the overlying theme for me
being a man is about knowing who I am
treating others well and trying to
follow those things every day being able
to talk skincare is something that's
important it's important to take pride
in yourself I feel like a man knows who
he is and is able to make others feel
good about who they are